عز كبير في مواجهه الاحتجاجات يعاني منه
نظام الايراني منذ بدايه تلك الاحداث
لتلجا القوات الامنيه الايرانيه الى
اساليب قمعيه بدات بالاعتقالات
والاختيالات ولن تنتهي عند الاعدامات التي
تكاد فرملاتها تكون يوميه تشمل محتاجين
ومؤيدين للاحتجاجات كالفنانين ولاعبي كره
القدم والمثقفين عزو النظام قابله اسرار
كبير من المحتاجين على مواصله المظاهرات
والاضرابات ضاربين تحديدات النظام عرض
الحائط ليس هدف حسب المحتاجون الايرانيون
لجوا الى اساليب وطرق جديده في الاحتجاجات
لتصعيد وتيره احتجاجاتهم اذا عمدوا الى
تغيير استراتيجيه التظاهر من النهار الى
الليل حيث باتوا يركزون على الفترات
المسائيه للخروج باحتجاجات تملا الشوارع
كما هو الحال في العاصمه طهران
كذلك الامر
حيث خرجت مظاهرات ليليه رددا فيها
المحتاجون امراه حياه حريه وشعار سيسقط
نظام خامنئي هذا العام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]